[Música]
hola les damos la bienvenida a enlace a
centroamérica desde san salvador en el
programa de hoy haremos un balance del
uso del beat coin en el salvador
contaremos cómo ha funcionado durante
estos tres meses desde que fue
establecido en el país como moneda de
curso legal organismos financieros como
el fondo monetario internacional o el
banco mundial han expresado dudas sobre
esta iniciativa ya que le agregaría una
volatilidad innecesaria al sistema
dolarizado con este tema daremos inicio
a este programa luego abordaremos el
aprovechamiento que el país hace de la
energía que se aloja en el subsuelo
concretamente la energía volcánica y por
último nos enfocaremos en conocer si el
flujo de remesas que entran al país ha
significado un revulsivo del uso del
víctor entre las familias salvadoreñas
el beat coin entró en vigencia en medio
de protestas para oponerse a la
principal apuesta económica del gobierno
los sondeos de opinión revelan que este
es el primer proyecto del presidente
nayib ukelele rechazado por buena parte
de la población en el centro capitalino
el gran corazón del comercio informal es
evidente la falta de información y la
apatía frente al cripto activo la
mayoría de los pequeños establecimientos
ni siquiera tienen avisos para informar
a sus clientes se aceptan o no el
bitcoin como forma de pago
la mayoría de las personas andan la
aplicación pero no
los que no lo saben utilizar no saben
cómo recibir no saben cómo enviar
entonces este
como quede más práctico que en dólares
en billetes
que
no es mucho ahorita sin embargo después
de tres meses algunos pensaban de que
iba a ser mucho menos que ya nadie va
andar pagando con la cripta moneda sin
embargo han dado muchas personas pagando
con la cripta moneda
escépticos por la inestabilidad del
valor de una moneda que no pueden palpar
y el requisito de contar con un teléfono
inteligente para usar la cripto divisa
la adopción masiva del bitcoin parece
difícil a eso habría que sumar que el
salvador es un país con modesta
infraestructura tecnológica y en donde
sólo el 45 por ciento de su población
tiene acceso a internet no obstante el
gobierno asegura que más de 3 millones
de salvadoreños ya están usando la
billetera estatal chivo luego que se
anunciara un bono equivalente a 30
dólares en bitcoin a quien la
descargarán conversamos con ricardo
castaneda economista del instituto
centroamericano de estudios fiscales
sobre los alcances que la cripto moneda
ha tenido a tres meses de estar
circulando entre los salvadoreños
hasta el momento no ha habido ningún
anuncio importante que permita realmente
demostrar que por esta ley el salvador
se ha convertido ahora en un centro para
la atracción de inversiones
seguramente en un par de meses podremos
comprobar la cifra pero vamos a ver que
no ha habido un cambio significativo
el salvador está ubicado sobre el
cinturón de fuego del pacífico' cuenta
con 23 volcanes y cinco campos
volcánicos en actividad el calor del
subsuelo se ha convertido en una
importante fuente de energía
convirtiendo al país en pionero del
desarrollo de la geotermia en
centroamérica
esa energía será aprovechada ahora para
minar bitcoin y no sólo eso también dará
vida a la primera ciudad bitcoin en el
oriente del país una especie de silicon
valley que según lo ha anunciado
recientemente por el presidente bucl se
alimentará de la energía volcánica
aunque la geotérmica es una de las
energías limpias o renovables
ecologistas consideran que este tipo de
proyectos conllevan a muchos efectos
medioambientales que podrían empeorar la
crisis energética mundial y el cambio
climático además de generar escasez de
energía y aumento de precios en la
tarifa eléctrica
no debería permitir ser minado de
bitcoin el salvador porque la capacidad
es ecosistémicas en el país no permiten
desarrollar ese tipo de industrias sin
que lo pague a alguien quien lo va a
pagar es lo que siempre pagan las crisis
la población más pobre y vulnerable y
los ecosistemas
el gobierno ha promovido la adopción del
bitcoin como una medida para eliminar el
pago de comisiones por el envío de
remesas desde estados unidos las cuales
suelen superar el 10 por ciento nos
trasladamos al municipio de
sensuntepeque un pequeño pueblo remesero
para conocer si fue aceptado el uso de
la cripta moneda entre sus habitantes
para recibir dinero desde el extranjero
esta entrada de divisas sostiene la
economía salvadoreña en el 2021 se
proyecta que ronda los 7 mil millones de
dólares una quinta parte del pib según
datos del banco central de reserva todo
un récord histórico según estimaciones
oficiales más de 3 millones de
salvadoreños viven fuera del país y
entre las principales razones de su
partida está en la economía la
reunificación familiar y la inseguridad
pues desde meses siempre me las envían
en dólares y siempre he preferido que
las remesas me las envíen en dólares
porque es una forma para mí más fácil de
sacarla hasta aquí con este enlace
centroamérica desde el salvador gracias
por habernos acompañado y para ver
nuestros programas síguenos en francés
24 y france 24 puntocom